ايه ده مشاهدينا صار موضوع يومي معنا خلاص
طبعا الامير هاري واللي عم يعملوا او
بالاصح اللي بيفجروا من تصريحات عن
العائله المالكه في سلسله مقابلات هو اصلا
عم يروش فيها لمك مو مذكرات مليانه فضايح
وجدل من وقت حلقه امبارح لليوم في مقابلات
وتفاصيل جديده طلعت هذا غير انه اليوم طرح
رسميا الكتاب حول العالم لتفكير بس من اول
يوم كان مقرر للمذكرات انها بتطرح في 10
يناير لكنها نزلت بكير كم يوم في اسبانيا
تحديدا
خلينا مشاهدينا نختصر سريعا سوا ابرز
الجدل اللي اجى في الكتاب والمقابلات هذه
بدايه قال انه العيله المالكه بتتعامل مع
الصحافه الصفراء اللي وصفها بالشيطان لا
تحسين صورتهم على حساب الاخرين هو كمان
قال انه الملك تشاز بيغار من زوجته ماجن
وزوجته
وانه بيسرقوا او بيخاف من انه يسرقوا منه
الاضواء هذه كمان في هذه المذكرات وهاي
المقابلات الناريه اتهم
يعني اخوه وزوجه اخوه انه ما كانوا مرحبين
بانضمام ميغان وحكموا عليها بالصوره
النبطيه
حريق كمان انه او تحدث بشكل مستب ايضا عن
غيره بينه وبين اخوه ووصفه بعده اللدود و
روى تفاصيل عن خناقه اخوه او خناقه خلالها
اخوه ضربوا في عام 2019 وكانت كل الخناقه
بسبب
نشر ايضا هو نشر مضمون رسائل نصيه ما بين
وكاثر بسبب فستان الاميره تشارليت
هاي طبعا خناقه مجنن تكلمت عنها لاول مره
في مقابله اوبرا وقالت انه بسببها قعدت
تبكي على الارض حكى الامير هاري كمان عن
توسله هو واخوه لوالد الملك انه ما يتزوج
كامله ووصف كامله بالشريره بالخطيره زي ما
انتم شايفين مشاهدينا تصريحات ناريه كثير
همم من ضمنها ايضا حكى عن وفاه والدته
وتعامل ابوه معه وعن ذهابه منجمه لحتى
يحاول يتواصل مع امه في قبرها والمقارنه
المستمره ما بين امه
حكى ايضا عن قتله 25 مسلح من طالبان في
افغانستان وهو في سلاح الجو البريطاني همم
وكيف انه هذا الموضوع او على الاقل خدمته
في افغانستان عدد ساعدته على تخطي صدمه
وفاه ام ايضا الامير هريره والتفاصيل عن
فقدان عذريته وهو في عمر 17 سنه مع امراه
تكبره في العمر في حقل خلف بار وحكى عن
تعطيل المخدرات والحشيش في شبابه قال كمان
انه هو ما راح يرجع ولا بريطانيا ابدا
طبعا بعد كل هذا قال انه بيرغب في
المصالحه مع ابوه اخوه بس هم اللي ما بدهم
ولا ابدوا اي استعداد لهذا الموضوع الامير
هاري من يوم ما ترك العائله المالكه
مشاهدينا هو وزوجته من بعدها بعدها طبعا
مقابله اوبرا الشهيره لكلنا طلعنا عليها
وسلسله كمان التصريحات اللي طلعت منه ضد
العائله المالكه بعدها من وقتها يعني اكثر
من الناس ضده
لانه في نفس الوقت كان في شريحه كبيره
متعاطفا معه معها ايضا يعني مع زوجته
وشايفين انه اللي عملوه مبرر ومفهوم خاصه
في امريكا على ما يبدو هناك في تعاطف كبير
الامريكان سواء مواطنين او حتى اعلان
كانوا بنسبه كبيره متعاطفين فيهم لكن
الملاحظه الان انه من بعد هذه المذكرات
وسلسله المقابلات الاخيره الوضع تغير
وسائل اعلام امريكيه بدات تنقلب عليهم على
فكره مش بس وسائل الاعلام ولكن شريحه
كبيره من المواطنين من حول العالم من
مكانه متعاطفين مع هاري وماجن وحابينهم
بعد كل الفضائح المنشوره هلا قلبوا عليهم
وشايفين اللي عم بيصير مش طبيعي وكثير زاد
عن حدهم على كل حال احنا راح نحكي فيه كل
هذه النقاط مع ابزال
مسؤوله سياسات في الجمعيه الملكيه
البريطانيه والمعلقه السياسي هو معنى
الامن المنظم اهلا بك استاذ ارزال راح
ابلش معك برؤيتك كيف بتنظر ل همم المذكرات
الامير هاري لكل التصريحات الناريه اللي
انحكت في المقابلات الاخيره اللي عملها
طبعا كلها كانت لترويش لك
كيف تنظر لها
الجزيره
من القلق وقد فاجئت الكثيرين
وقد صدمت الكثيرين في راي العام
البريطاني الذين دعموه هاري عندما تزوج مع
البريطانيين
الاسره الملكه وفي المؤسسات البريطانيه
الكثيرين في المملكه المتحده هؤلاء يرون
الان بانه يستخدم هذا الكتاب
ماليه
لزياده شعبيه
كل ذلك
بالفعل شعبيه الامير هاري وماجن انخفضت
بشكل كبير زي ما هو يعني بلشنا نشوف او
لانه زادت الانتقادات على هيئه تصريحات
الناريه اللي عملها كل هذه الفضائح اللي
كشف عنها هل داخل بريطانيا انخفضت عين
نسبه خصوصا همم في همم يعني بين الشباب
اللي كانوا بشكل عام داعمين
شاب همم
نظرائي كلهم يتفقون على انه حتى
يرون وجه مختلف همم
اقل وهناك من يشعر بالحرج
لا يمكن ان يدعمه ابدا
طيب ماذا بالنسبه للولايات المتحده يعني
في امريكا العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
يعني هو موضوع اهتمام كبير من قبل عامه
الشعب وحتى الفنانين والسياسيين وغيره هل
ايضا نلاحظ انه حتى
الولايات المتحده اللي هي بتحضنهم هلا
دست كيس
عندما
اجره المقابله مع اوبرا وينفري يعتقد
الزوج ان الشعبيتهما سوف تزداد وان الناس
سوف يرون الحقيقه خلف الاسره الملكه ومحدث
حتى هو ان حتى الامريكيين الذين يحترمون
كثيرا الاسره الملكه
البريطانيه
الكثير من القصص المزيفه في المقابله
خاصه وانهما
ذهاب الى امريكا
وورده اذا كان هناك عدم قبول لهما في
امريكا الى اين سيذهبان الان
اسال عليك وايضا الامير ويليام بعد هذه
التصريحات التي ادلى بها هاري هل تاثرت
باي شكل من الاشكال ام بالعكس اكبر خصوصا
في المملكه المتحده
بسبب المقابلات فان الاحصاءات اظهرت باننا
الشعبيه
شعبيه
في المملكه المتحده
شعبيته لم تتاثر وهو يحفظ
كثير فاعتقد ان الناس ادركوا ان الملك او
الاميره ويليام يقومان
بواجباتهما بطريقه تحذف الكثير من
الاحترام طيب
هل جنه الامير هاري خصوصا انه بنتي اد
العائله الملكه في بعض الشغلات مثل انهم
بيتعاملوا مع الشيطان يعني الصحفي الصفراء
وعم بعطي يعني كل الاخبار هاي اللي عم
بحكي فيها للصحه في الصفراء على طبق من
ذهب
الجمله هو انها يقوم
باطعام
الحيوان
وهو الان يوفر هذه المعلومات وبالتالي هذه
سوف ينعكس عليه واعتقد نعم الامير هاري
اخطا كثيرا في ما قام به وهو يحرج نفسه
اكثر من اي شخص اخر شكرا
البريطانيه والمعلقه السياسيه